welcome to the presentation of a split
bow euclidean capacitated vehicle
routing my name is Hanzo
my name is Claire Matthew
this is trying to work with public
imagine you own a truck delivery company
and you must organize the delivery of
packages to customers
how would you model this kind of problem
in this work we study the capacity of
the vehicle routing problem cvrp
that you define the CVR key
we are given at the point O and a set of
n terminals each terminal has an
unsplitable demand in zero one the
demand of a terminal cannot be split
you mean
if you need to deliver a package to some
address
you are not allowed to open it and split
it into several pieces and deliver them
separately
yes this what hospital means
there is a unlimited number of identical
vehicles
the tour of each vehicle starts at the
Depot and the returns there after
visiting terminals of total demand at
most one
one represents the capacity of the
vehicle
together the tools must cover ornaments
the objective is to minimize the total
length of the toes
for example in the figure to the left
the Blue terminal has demand equal to
0.2
on the figure to the right
the solution consists of three towards
red yellow and green
you can check that for the red tour for
example the total demand 0.4 0.3.2.1
sum to one
so it does not exceed the capacity
cvrp is fundamental in operations
research
okay so now we understand the problem
wow
that's a lot of references
yes cvrp is a well-studied problem
what are all these colors
the color depends on the metric space in
which the problem is studied it has been
studied on General Matrix euclidium
plane landographs trees graphs of
boundary widths graphs of boundary
Highway Dimension and graphic Matrix
okay why are there two columns
because there are two settings the
restricted setting in which all demands
are equal and the general setting in
which the demands might be unequal so
that's more General
yes that's a more general setting
in this work we consider the setting of
unequate events
our focus is the cvrp on the equilibrium
plane
okay
now we understand how this work fits in
the general context
so now that we understand the problem
and the context
what is the result
our main result is a two plus Epsilon
approximation for rb3 demands
two plus Epsilon
is this better than what was known
before
yes the previous best approximation
algorithm has a ratio of
2.694 due to Quick Start than others
hmm
okay so that's better could you do even
better or is there a lower bound
theories a lower bound of 1.5
so
could you get an approximation that
would be between 1.5 and 2 even better I
don't know
okay
how do you go about obtaining a two plus
Epsilon approximation
the idea is to Cluster the small
terminals into groups of total demand
roughly Epsilon
and then we are in the special case in
which ornaments are big
could you do even better than OnePlus
Epsilon a polynomial time algorithm
perhaps
no because the problem is empty half
you said that this holds for unequal
demands but the problem has previously
been studied for the special case of
equal demands
so how do your results compare to those
both our results match the best known
approximation factors in the
corresponding equal demand settings
now I'm going to present our result on
the euclidian cvrp for big demands only
let Epsilon do some positive constant
we say that a demand is big if it is at
least Epsilon and is small otherwise
when ornaments are big it is easy to
design a polynomial time exact algorithm
if both of the two assumptions hold
first we assume that there is a constant
number of locations
second we assume that there is a
constant number of distinct demands at
each location
you say it's easy but
how do you do it
by Brute Force
each tool only covers a bounded number
of Demands at abundant number of
locations so there are only abounded a
number of two configurations which you
can enumerate in polynomial time
okay I understand that when the two
assumptions holds the problem is easy
but how do you achieve both assumptions
so let's see the first assumption
reducing the number of locations how can
we reduce the number of locations
to reduce the number of locations zero
three steps in the first step we reduce
the instance to boundary distance which
means that the ratio between the minimum
distance to the depot and the maximum
distance to the depot is greater than
Epsilon
in the figure the maximum distance is D
and the minimum distance is at least
Epsilon D and all points belong to the
gray area
how can you achieve this bounded
distance property
to achieve the boundary distance
property we use Baker's shifting
technique by losing a one plus Epsilon
factor in approximation
okay so now we can assume bounded
distance
in the second step we decompose the gray
area into a constant number of regions
called cells for example the green
region is a cell
for people familiar with running
techniques in approximation algorithms
this is standard
in the third step we move each terminal
to the center of the cell
so this is the green cell of the
previous slide
the terminals are the 12 blue dots on
the picture
and the center of the cell is the black
dot in the picture
when we do that for every cell we have
reduced the number of locations to a
constant
we can show that the total cost of
moving the terminals to the centers is
negligible
okay I understand that you can now
assume that the number of locations is
constant
what about the second assumption that
the number of Demands is constant
now we reduce the number of distinct
demands at each location
we apply the Adaptive rounding technique
introduced by Fernandez De la Vega and
luica
in the context of designing an
approximation scheme for Venta Kenya
consider any Center first we sort all
demands at the center in non-decreasing
order
these are the 12 black bullets on the
top figure
next we make groups of equal cardinality
these are the three groups each of four
bullets
and finally in each group we run the
demands up to the maximum demand in that
group
on the bottom figure you can see that in
each group The Bullet have moved
but
when you increase the demands like this
if you had the solution that was
previously within capacity now maybe it
would exceed the capacity
so this would change everything
it's just a light analysis of thinking
okay
so now we have achieved the two
assumptions
a constant number of locations
and
a constant number of distinct demands at
each location
now we summarize our algorithm for big
demands only in the first step reduce
two pounded distance in the second step
we decompose into cells in the third
step we move each big terminal to the
center of its cell in the first step we
apply the Adaptive rounding technique on
the demands at each Center and in the
last step we solve the resulting
instance in polynomial time
this completes the description of the
OnePlus Epsilon approximation for the
euclidean cvrp and pick the lens only
until now we assume all demands are big
Now we move on to our main result on rb3
demands
now some demands may be small
let us step back and think about cvrp in
general
theories are simple well-known algorithm
called iterated to a partitioning
introduced by high vomish and ludican in
1985.
since we will draw some inspiration from
their algorithm first as a warm-up let
us review how that works
iterated to a partitioning
the algorithm is very simple
there are three steps first we compute a
tsp tool on all terminals weight
a tsp tour
but it does not respect the capacity
constraints
yes in this step we ignore the tool
capacity
next we partition the tool into segments
each of total demand and most one
on the figure
we have partitioned the two into three
segments each segment has total demand
at most one
finally for each segment we connect its
endpoints to the depot by adding the
orange connection
in this way on the figure we get three
tools each tour is within capacity
in the utility space
it is known that this algorithm is a two
plus Epsilon approximation when
ornaments are small and is a three plus
Epsilon approximation when the demands
are arbitrary
okay
so that was iterated toward partitioning
now we design a more efficient algorithm
for RPG demands
there are two cases depending on the
number of tools in optimal solution
the most interesting case is when the
optimal solution has sufficiently made
it to us which is our Focus here
we adapt from our previous algorithm for
big demands only
how do we deal with small demands
as before we decompose the plane into
cells
the key is to Cluster the small demands
of each cell into big demands
at a high level we group the small
terminals that are near one another in
the cell into clusters
our clustering approach is a modified
version of the iterated tour
partitioning
this slide is the part of the algorithm
that will have the most interesting
analysis
first we compute a tsp Tour on the small
terminals in the cell not in the whole
input but just in the cell
next we partition the tool into segments
each of total demand wrap the Epsilon
not segments of demand 1 but segments of
demand Epsilon
finally for each segment we cluster its
terminals into a big terminal and a
place that big terminal at the center of
the cell
to that end
we add orange connections between the
endpoints of the segments and the center
of the cell not the depot but the center
of the cell
okay so now all demands are big but now
I have a question
what is the cost of this clustering
in the next few slides we analyze the
cost of our solution this is the most
technical part of this talk
that opt denote the cost of an optimal
solution to the initial instance
we show a number one that the cost of
our solution within sales is at most
OnePlus 2 Epsilon times opt
to prove level 1 consider any cell
the green curves are the optimal
solution within the cell
we include the blue part of the boundary
of the cell to make the green curves
connected
so we obtain a tsp tool visiting Auto
minerals in the cell
then we partition the tsp tool into
segments of total demand roughly Epsilon
and we add the orange connections
between the endpoints of the segments
and the center of the cell
the overall cost of the green curves
over all cells is at the most odd
in each cell the cost of the blue part
is at most 1.5 times the boundary of the
cell by cups argument
since the number of cells is a constant
well the optimum solution has a super
constant number of tools the overall
cost of the blue Parts over all cells is
at the most Epsilon time spot
it remains to analyze the cost of the
orange connections
since each segment of the tsp tool has
total demand roughly Epsilon so cost of
the orange segments can be bonded in the
same way as the cost of moving the big
terminals to the centers
so the overall cost of the orange
connections is that most Epsilon times
opt
this concludes the proof of Lemma 1.
now I'm going to bound the cost between
cells let opt Prime denote the cost of
an optimal solution to the clustered
instance
since the classroom instance consists of
big demands only we apply the previous
algorithm to obtain a OnePlus Epsilon
approximation
so the cost between sales is at most one
plus Epsilon times opt Prime
it remains to bound opt Prime with
respect to opt
to that end we construct a new Optimum
solution to the clustered instance as
follows
first we compute a by criteria
resolution consisting of a set of tools
each of capacity 1 plus Epsilon
this can be achieved using assignment
number by background report
the cost of the bytecrity resolution is
at the most OnePlus Epsilon times opt
in order to make the solution feasible
we remove one cluster from each tool so
that the total demand of that tour is
within one
it remains to cover the removed glasses
to that end we include a tsp tool to
connect the remote clusters
since each cluster is at some Center its
devices for the tsp tool to visit all
the sensors
since there is a constant number of
centers and the number of tools in the
optimum solution is super constant the
cost of the tsp 2 is negligible
finally we applies iterated tour
partitioning on the tsp tool to obtain a
set of tools within capacity
the cost of this step is negligible
since only Epsilon demand is removed
from each tool
now we showed that the overall cost
between sales is at most OnePlus 4
Epsilon times out
combining number one and the Lemma 2 we
conclude that the overall cost of our
solution is at the most two plus six
Epsilon times out
Now we move on to the second case when
optimal solution has a bounded number of
tools the algorithm for this case is an
adaptation of Aurora's algorithm for
euclidian csb
in the first step we run down each
demand to an integer multiple of one
over two n in the second step we apply
Aurora's algorithm to the rounded
instance
the solution to the rounded instance can
be transformed into a Bugatti resolution
to the initial instance where the total
demand of each tool is at most 1.5
in the last step we split each tool into
two tools each within the capacity
now we analyze the cost of our solution
the Second Step has cost at most one
plus Epsilon times the optimum cost
according to Aurora
in the third step the cost is the most
doubled
so the overall cost is the most two plus
two Epsilon times odd
to conclude let me recap our results
in this talk we gave a two plus Epsilon
approximation for rp3 demands to solve
that problem
we also gave a one plus Epsilon
approximation for big demands only
observe that for artificial demands
there is a gap between the lower bound
of 1.5 and the upper bound of 2 plus
Epsilon in approximation
coming back to the application to track
delivery is our algorithm practical
let's see
partitioning demands into cells that is
into geographical areas
that seems natural
clustering small demands in the same
cell into larger demands seems
reasonable
solving the big demand Problem by which
force can be replaced by a heuristic
that will be faster or maybe we could
use integer programming
so any heuristic to solve
as well as we can
and finally there are several steps
where we use Aurora's tsp approximation
scheme and that is not a practical but
that part could be replaced also by a
heuristic
all together maybe some adaptation of
our algorithm might be useful in
practice
that's the end of our talk thank you